首先强调一下啊，致之愈合的电影，很多同学呢很喜欢啊文艺青年嘛，强烈要求啊，我给大家讲一讲失之愈合，今天就满足大家要求。
首先表明一下我的态度啊，第一个态度。
我也喜欢时之玉合，蛮喜欢他的叙事风格，蛮喜欢他的画面，也蛮喜欢他的配乐。
也很喜欢他的台词，他的文学功底。
这是我的第一个态度。第二个态度我不推荐。
咱们的学生小白。
呃，写这种故事。
进入这个圈子啊，或者是作为你头几年吃饭的一个路子呃不行啊，不行，我的学生。
在年轻的时候，先写商业篇啊，先把钱挣了，先活下去。
是我的两个态度，我先讲在前面。好吧，来，咱们正式开始上课。第一个议题，我们调查分析一下咱们的同学当中对这部片子的看法，我们就分两个维度，喜欢的扣一，不喜欢的扣2，喜欢的居多。然后呢，当然肯定有同学会觉得节奏有点慢，这个是不可避免的啊来。
这个虽然他是个文艺片啊，开始认知他，我们依然需要先拉信息结拍啊。第一拍啊家庭在家里母女一个对话戏的开场，然后交代了一些信息，比如说父亲刚刚去世，他们还在处理父亲去世的事情，家庭不太好，先交代了一下，然后也交代了一下家庭成员是吧？有姐姐有有有有儿子，儿子虽然不在，但是呢也。
母亲也表达出了对儿子的偏爱。
呃，另外一个很重要的伏笔是呢台风预告已经开始了。好吧，因为台风天是这个片子最大的一个包裹啊。第二拍。
从第三分钟开始啊，男主角登场啊，男主角乘着车，包括在路边吃简单的一个荞麦面，也交代了这个男主角啊，50岁的一个人，但是活的挺落魄的。这里呢他其实是一个回家的路啊，回家的路上交代了几个小伏笔，一个是交代了那个章鱼滑梯啊，章鱼滑梯，我们说这是个最后。
高潮系的场景，而且这个章鱼滑梯代表了封存的梦想。咱们有时候说有些道具它代表了什么是我们过度解读。但但是在这部影片当中没有任何过度解读，事之一合，就怕把这个封存的梦想写在刻在这个章鱼滑梯上了，都已经非常凶狠的表达了自己的一些比喻啊。
所以说这个张玉滑题代表了丰城的梦想。当然回来回家的路上，通过碰到邻居交代了一个很重要的信息，就是男主角曾经很辉煌。在学校的时候就是风云人物，因为是个文艺小青年，年轻的时候写小说还得过奖，辉煌的前史啊，这个东西呃是是很重要的。
有些同学说，无法共情男主。对。
你确实有些同学会觉得无法共情男主，因为你还没有活到他这个岁数。
或者是你没有他这样的经历，我其实非常能共情这个男主。我在30岁的时候，第一次三十几岁的时候，第一次看这个片子就能非常共情这个男主。我待会儿给大家讲啊。
第三拍第7分钟开始啊。
男主角回家翻东西啊，找钱呀，找当票呀，对吧？还找一幅值钱的画啊，有一幅值钱的画是他第一个目标记一下啊。男主角第一个目标这个这个包括妈妈跟他的对话说那个橘子树嘛，不成才的橘子树不成才的儿子啊。
同时也再次暗示台风要将近，然后玻璃还被打碎了啊，屋漏偏逢连夜雨，台风要来了，玻璃还碎了。然后呢，我们的男主角还躲起来接接这个崔债的电话，对吧？再一次彰显他的落魄，甚至想偷妈妈的钱是吧？但是死要面子。
给妈妈零花钱。
嗯，但是妈妈想要房子，哎，同学们看啊，这个一拍分钟数很长啊，这个在别的戏里面很少见呃，这也是这种片子的一个一个特点吧。好吧，十分钟的一场戏，然后第四拍第17分钟。
呃，妈妈送儿子出门的时候呢，遇到音乐老师在老师面前显摆自己的儿子是吧？显摆自己的儿子，然后两个人走路去车站，回忆自己的父亲呀，回忆这个章鱼呃，又提到这个张鱼滑梯呀，包括谈到儿子和前妻，把儿子有一个前妻和有一个儿子这件事情交代出来。
然后也侧面交代了母亲其实并没有忘记父亲啊。但是这场戏最重要的是什么呀？
第四拍最重要的是交代母亲。
在学音乐这件事情。当然，章云滑梯的信息也很重要，儿子前妻的儿子和前妻的信息也很重要，呃，思念父亲的信息也有用。但是最重要的这一场其实是交代母亲在学音乐，这是第四拍。
第五拍啊，第21。
分钟男主角到当铺去，父亲呢也是这里的常客啊，然后嘞。
他不是要找一幅值钱的画吗？这这个目标在这里落空了啊，在第21分钟落空了，那幅画其实根本不存在。
然后呢，这里开始已经开始明示。我跟大家讲啊，在这部电影当中没有暗示，全都是明示，明白吧？因为这是一部作者电影，作者没有必要跟你玩弯弯绕是吧？什么不需要你过度解读，他自己就过度解读了。明示他在走父亲的老路啊，他会成为他的父亲。
第六拍第22分钟啊，男主角回到工作场景，他是一个私家侦探。然后呢，他和他的同事，那个小小帅哥啊，他的同事一起合伙赚黑钱啊，赚灰色收入，吃两家。可以理解啊，当当那个私家侦探窥探别人的隐私，很容易吃两家，这是第六拍。
第七拍到第25分钟。
他刚赚到钱，对吧？吃两家刚拿到钱，然后又去赌博，赌博输光了，输光了，又问同事借钱，露出他的这个赌棍的嘴脸啊，包括有很多理由，他说了很多很荒诞的那种赌棍才会说的话，是吧？什么自行车是没有刹车的是吧？就赌棍给自己心理建设嘛，第八盘第八拍28分钟。
两个人回到公司，这个公司呢也是主打一个骗钱主打一个骗钱。为什么主打这个老板是个骗钱的家伙呢？为什么呢？是为了捞一捞我们主角的形象，咱们有很多同学不共情这个主角，是因为这个主角实在是太烂了，对吧？又赌，然后又偷妈妈的钱啃老。
是吧，然后又又又在工作中撒谎，简直一无是处。所以很多同学呢带入不了这个主角，然后就很讨厌他，，对吧？肯定有很多这样的同学吧。呃，所以在这里呢你可以理解这场戏为什么表表现一下这个公司的老板主打骗钱和抠门呢？是想往回捞一捞这个男主他赚灰钱是有可理性？
往回捞一捞这个男主他赚灰钱，赚赚黑钱是有合理性的啊，就把他工作当中骗钱这件事情往回轻微的捞了一下啊。
在聊男人小心眼儿这个话题的时候，在谈话中引出。
他其实也在监视他前妻好吧，这第八拍的一个作用啊。第九拍30分钟，男主角回到自己的家，要，回到自己住的那个住租住的小房子，他的生活非常的落魄和拮据啊。但是但是在坚持写作。
他说他在私家侦探社只是在找灵感，这件事情不是找理由，他确实是在坚持写作。
这个很重要啊，他回到家以后，把今天记录的素材哎，记素材有没有你有没有坚持记素材啊？
人家都坚持啊。
把今天听到的对吧？说过的话，听到过的好的东西。
记下来。
当然了，生活确实很落魄啊，担心房租呀、担心水电费呀。
然后第十拍第32分钟啊，跟踪监视他的前妻儿子以及新的男朋友，包括打棒球呀、饭店呀，对吧？而且还和儿子在饭店的厕所偷偷见面，简直不能再猥琐了。而且而且大家有没有发现一点。他儿子异常的淡定。
对吧爱他就说明他儿子不是第一次这样跟他见面了，他儿子真的是习惯他了，这个不成才的爹。
然后嘞，然后还调查人家。
调查人家对吧？前妻的男朋友，但是在这一天的跟踪戏里面交代了几个有用的信息啊。第一个信息就是父子两个人很默契，他们俩的棒球理念是一样的。
通过棒球理念这件事情交代了父子俩是有默契的，而且这个理念会贯穿到后面的做人和梦想。
然后第二个信息就是他被这个男人彻底取代了，用的是美津浓的一个手套，日本的一个牌子啊，他已经被这个男人彻底取代了啊，然后这是一个有用信息，还有一个有用信息，就是他的妻子在新的男朋友面前依然在维护。
他的尊严。
这个也是一个有用信息啊，他的妻子按理说啊他也不交赡养费，又离婚了，对吧？然后又是个赌徒不成才，他老婆因此跟他离婚，现在找了一个有钱的男朋友，按理说咱们如果是这个女孩呃，咱们是不可能去维护咱们的前夫的。但是她依然在维护自己的前夫。
就这一点还是蛮重要的。同学们记得这个点吗？你们有看到这个点吗？
就是在聊起前夫的作品的时候，前期眼睛里还是有光的，说明什么呢？说明第一。
前嗯我们的男主角曾经真的有才华。
对不对？
不然也不会得奖嘛，不然也不会以写作为梦想嘛。曾经真的。
很努力啊，很棒过。第二呢，这个这个。
前期对他还是有感情的对吧？
然后来到第1一排，也就是第39分钟，男主角接到一个活。
接到一个什么活呢？
写一个赌博题材的漫画的活。
报酬很多。
但是很不体面。
一个赌博题材的漫画的活，当然了，咱们不了解人家日本的国情，反正我们可以知道这个活赚钱多，但是不体面，可能就是写那种小黄文嘛，赌博题材嘛肯定是歪门邪道。
他嘴硬拒绝了。对，赌博题材不一定是歪门邪道。但在这个影片里，你们去理解一下啊，咱们不是来讨论赌博题材应应应该写或者漫画应不应该写，你理解一下在这个剧情里面。
这个活不体面，你能体会这个剧情吗？
不是说赌博体材就一定是歪门邪道啊，我没有阻止你们写赌博体材。第十二拍第40分钟啊，第12拍第40分钟。
去找姐姐借钱啊，然后呢，姐姐其实只是一个营业员啊，其实也没什么钱。
然后呢对。
通过这场戏再次交代啊，他跟他又带走他父亲的老路。因为他爸爸也曾经来跟女儿借钱啊，一家人两个男人都很没出息。
啊，这场戏有个小伏笔，他打探到了母亲藏钱的地方，，打探到了母亲，喜欢把钱藏在柜子里。
然后第十三拍43分钟。
再次。
啊，再次来到母亲的音乐间场课。
母亲的音乐音乐鉴上课很重要啊。
然后嘞。
这里音乐这场课结束之后，分手的那场戏比较有意思啊，分手的那场戏，咱们主角的呃这个老妈妈，也就是咱们这个老太太呢是住在你可以理解是住在宿舍区的啊，他们叫宿舍区，其实你就可以理解就是安置房啊。呃，咱们的主角是住在安置房的。
但是呢参加的却是这个公寓社区就是高档社区的音乐班聚会。那场戏很明显啊，而且他还挺刻意的表现自己呢，他很刻意的融入是吧？抢着回答问题，然后嘞哎告别了啊告别了高档的社区。
你看就是这个镜头。
就是这个镜头啊，告别了高档的社区，然后要走过围墙，走过铁路，回到他们的安置房啊，你他们叫公寓。当然了，这场戏啥意思？我说主题是啥来着？
这个电影主题是啥来着？同学们回答我来，这个电影主题是梦想。那这个老太太在干什么？不切实际的梦想嘛。
你个农村老太太还去听贝多芬。
是不是啊？
不切实际的梦想呀。所以你现在能理解他为什么能理解自己的儿子吗？当然了啊，这里还有一个信息点，就是他回家又开始做那个自制的那个冰淇淋啊，其实就一碗冰，你们小时候可能没经历过，我小时候经历过，拿一个玻璃杯，放点糖水，我们当时不是放糖水啊。
我小时候是80年代，我们是拿一杯水放点卖乳精，那而且也不是很小的时候，进城的时候啊吧，进城了才有这个细节交代什么啊？他在期待自己的儿子回家啊，他在期待自己的儿子回家。
好，第十四拍来到第47分钟，一组戏展现了男主的工作，展现了男主的工作。
都有哪些呢？
在事务所里被大家群嘲他跟踪前妻呃的事儿啊，劝他放手，而且呢也透露了一个重要的信息。就是其实他前妻再婚的话，可以减轻他的经济负担，他就不用再继续支付赡养费了啊。这是西方国家的一个法律，就是说呃你再婚了，就是前离婚再婚了。那这个前夫就不需要支只再支付赡养费了啊。
自己很落魄，但是他依然不愿意放手啊，然后他又跑去一个高中去执行任务，对吧？去高中执行任务的时候呢，谈及梦想。
他说自己不想成为父亲一样的人啊，他说自己不想成为父父亲一样的人，但是造化弄人。当然在这里也有一个金句啊，就是人很难成为你自己理想中的大人，对吧？
然后呢又去执行外勤的监视任务，再次强调啊，前期啊赚到钱要支付赡养费。
而且在执行任务的这个事务所呢，他一一直强调自己只是过渡阶段啊，这不是他的这不是他的职业，他只是一个过渡阶段暂时当这做这个工作。
然后他还是想当小说家，这个都交代了。因为那个事务所的所长劝他转劝他转正，他不转。
另外呢，他们赚的黑钱被发现了啊，被没收了。
所以他支付不了儿子的赡养费了，但是同事资助了他一点钱啊，那个帅帅的同事资助了他一点钱。
有同学在这里分了四盘，可以分四拍啊，但是四拍是同一个作用，就是主线以外到他的工作。因为主线啊是主角追求梦想，我们是贴出来让他展现一下他他他在工作场景里面的挣扎。你可以理解这四拍是一个作用。
理论上啊，如果这不是个文艺片的话，理论上这四拍应该配个BGM剪一个蒙太奇就可以了。对，这个版本翻译的不好啊，应该翻译成，别以为你能随便。
长成理想中的大人第15拍第59分钟啊，到了礼拜天了，然后呢去见前妻见儿子，但是呢没有没有钱啊，没有赡养费。呃，把儿子带走之后呢，带着去买鞋，打探消息。哎就然后呢有一场很重要的戏。嗯，带着儿子去买彩票啊，带着儿子去买彩票。
然后最后决定带儿子去妈妈家里啊，家没去妈妈家里。
然后呢。
镜头就一个电话之后，镜头就切到妈妈那里，再次预告要台风要来了啊。这个女儿预告这个儿子呢没安好心啊，没安好心是是来搞钱啊，十六拍第65分钟父子回家啊，在路上呢两个人谈了一些美好的童年回忆啊，谈为后面的梦想呀。
打伏比，谈及了很多美好的回忆。回到家之后呢，姐弟斗嘴，实际两个人都在啃老，大家发现没有啊？这姐弟两个人虽然这个姐姐有时候会借钱给爸爸和弟弟，但是其实两个人都在啃老啊，因为在日本咱们要了解一下日本的这个日本的这个国情啊，他们的这个老年人啊，实际上如果就是说年轻人的工作如果不好的话，实际上是没有老老年人赚得多的。
日本人的老年金比较丰厚啊，你可以理解日本人人均都是咱们这里的退休干部，比如说你上班一个月挣1万，但是老人的退休金呢一般有个1600、16000甚至2万是吧？就是当然了，可能没那么多啊，这种老人家庭呢，小孩可能就是赚的还没有老人的退休金多，所以所以去啃啃一啃呢。
也正常啊，没有那么不堪啊，啃一啃也正常啊。第十七拍。
69分钟。
前妻和台风都抵达了啊，然后被迫要待一会儿啊，被迫要待一会儿，一家人准备晚饭啊，一家人准备晚饭。但是我们的男主呢还在电记偷钱是吧？电记偷钱，然后呃这个一家人一起吃饭，男主呢讨好前妻。
妈妈在这时候强留下大家过夜。第1八拍来到第76分钟，妈妈呢跟这个这个前儿媳在炫耀儿子年轻时候的才华，对吧？然后也谈及了梦想，谈及了彩票啊，想买大房子呀。
然后第十九拍81分钟铺床啊，铺床睡觉。然后夫妻两个人呢在卧室里交谈，谈到了痛处。
谈到了未来啊。
当然也有小插曲，想骚扰一下人家。但是呢这个未遂。
但是那个在卧室里交谈，触及灵魂了。
第20拍来到第87分钟，半夜，男主在橱柜里找钱，发现被姐姐阴了啊，一个小幽默姐姐假装透露给他妈妈藏钱的地方，实际是骗他啊。
然后第2一拍啊第21拍。
第91分钟和妈妈两个人深夜谈心。
谈到了过去，谈到了死亡，谈到了陪伴。
谈到了父亲，也谈到了父亲的人生目标。
总是在追求已经失去的东西。
谈及了什么是幸福，什么是婚姻，也谈及了什么是比海更深。
总之，和妈妈这场谈身戏啊，谈心的戏我。
残疾了很多东西，然后第22拍来到第97分钟，儿子起业起来尿尿，然后呢，父子两个人冒雨偷偷跑去公园啊，就跑去章鱼滑梯。然后呢，母亲和前妻在家里啊继续写那个的玩意儿，然后呢，两个人也谈了一下心，各种话疗，然后呢也交接了这个孙子的脐带。
那场戏还挺感人的。
第23拍来到第103分钟，父子二人呢在这个公园的这个章鱼城堡里，章鱼滑梯里躲雨啊，吃零食，也他也开始化疗，谈到了爷爷啊，谈到了父子关系，谈到了三代人的关系，也谈到了儿子的梦想，儿子的梦想，跟自己小时候的梦想是一样的。
啊，呃竟然也是传承。在这里强调一下啊，有些同学可能不理解说父亲和儿子两个人都想成为公务员。在这里我们要理解一件事情啊，我们不能用我们的语境来理解这个问题。很多同学就会说，咦那父子两个人都想成为公务员的话。
说明这两个人没有什么梦想呀，他们俩是想尽体制，想考公呀。
说明这两个人挺务实的呀，挺鸡贼的呀。为什么会觉得他们两个人有梦想呢？你要通过国情来理解问题，我就担心你们理解成稳定的生活。在国外，公务员可以是梦想，就相当于什么呢？就相当相相当于问。
你的梦想是什么？
他说我要为人民奉献，我要为人民服务，你可以理解吗？不是政治抱负，你们搞错了。
在国外啊，公务员的待遇很低，但是可以服务这个社会，帮助弱势群体。所以说这个父子两个人是之前是有一个很崇高很梦幻的梦想的，你可以理解类似于支教，就就是想两个人想吃苦，想吃苦，想奉献。
24拍105分钟，妈妈也来到公园了，妈妈也来到公园找他们了，夫妻两个人在章鱼滑梯里交谈，争章鱼滑梯里是代表着梦想，两个人在章鱼滑梯里交谈，然后决定放手向前走。
2525拍第107分钟彩票丢了。刚才那拍记得重点啊，男主角决定放手向前走了。第25拍彩票丢了，一家人在雨中找彩票，这是本本本本片的大高潮啊，最感人的地方。一家人在雨中找彩票。
26拍108分钟。第二天早上，男主角穿上跟父亲一样的衣服，继续走父亲当年的路。
证明了什么证明了他也理解父亲了。
如果这场还没有证明，那看27拍110分钟，他跑到当铺，把那个砚台去做一下估值，想当掉对吧？
发现了父亲曾经收藏过他的书，认为他的书会大火，他会大卖，会赚大钱。非他的父亲也就是说，他的父亲曾经以他为骄傲。
所以他没有当掉这个砚台，甚至还用这个砚台写字，正式接过了父亲的笔，父亲的枪，父亲的梦想第28拍112分钟。
一家人告别了。
儿子呢带着彩票，带着球鞋，带着自己的理念继续去追求自己的梦想。
反衬之下，我们的男主角也一定会坚持自己的梦想。好吧，这就是整个故事啊，整个故事整个故事的主题就是梦想。我们说里面有多少个梦想啊，里面谈及了多少梦想啊，男主角的梦想写了吧。
男主角传承的是父亲和儿子的梦想，对吧？这三代男人的梦想，妈妈的梦想是什么？听音乐对吧？妈妈有音乐梦，还有他前妻呢。
他前期。
也说了，他前期想当老师，但是因为对吧？可能是因为要生孩子，要照顾家庭放弃了。因为在日本一般都是一个人上班，其实欧洲很多也这样啊，一旦形成家庭的话是一个人上班。所以说这个妈妈她原本是想当老师的。
他也有自己的梦想，整个故事讲的就是梦想啊，如果我们啊我们先说一下这个故事的启程转合啊。
首先这个故事啊严格来说也没有什么启程转合。当然了，我们是可以理出一些叙事脉络的。
首先这个故事讲的是什么呢？讲的是一个蹉跎半生的落魄中年人。
50岁了，同学们啊，他面临的情况是什么？这是人设离异失业破产，对吧？三重打击啊，然后呢是这么一个生活的现状。
他想要找回他自己啊，就是这么一个故事。那他找回他自己这个叙事的基本脉络是什么呢？
同学们，他为了找回他自己，他做了哪几哪几件事情的努力呢？你们共情一下啊。第一件事情上来他先要找什么啊？他认为什么能解决问题啊，他认为钱能解决问题。所以他整个故事的中前部一直延续到后面，他先找钱。
找偷钱也是找钱，当票、彩票、赌博都是找钱。所以说关于找钱他做了很多努力。
然后他为了找回自己的生活，还试图找回什么呢？除了找钱以外，家庭非常对，先找钱再找家庭，或者你理解这两件事情也算同步吧，一边找钱一边找家庭。最后他这两件事情都没找到。同学们，钱和家庭他都没找回来，他只找回来了一样东西是什么？
他就找回一个梦想，同学们思考一个问题啊，如果是一个商业片，是不是就反过来了？商业片的我们最后落脚点会落在珍惜眼前人。
放弃幻想，珍惜眼前人。上礼拜的夏洛特反闹是不是讲的是放弃梦想，珍惜眼前人，那是商业片。这个文艺片为什么说的是文艺片呢？
放下眼前的纠葛和执着，继续追求梦想吧。青年穿上你父亲的旧衣裳，拿起你父亲的破毛笔。
追求你的梦想吧。青年。
继续追求你的创作梦吧。同学们觉得这样的主题反而累吗？
其实还好吧，我觉得有两个原因啊，我就就就还好第一。
首先如果这种文艺片啊，他写这样的主题，它总是有一些修饰的啊，他也会有一些修饰的，不会让你觉得那么硬那么难受，对吧？因为他最后也理解了父亲，父亲确实也有才华呀。就父亲虽然赌了一辈子，当了一辈子，落魄了一辈子。但是他可能就是不被社会所理解嘛。
就第一个事情。
就人家还是有做一些艺术处理的。第二个事情就是还是要考虑日本的这个环境，就高度发达的一个资本主义国家。所以呢大部分人如果愿意上班都可以顺顺利利的过一生，就福利还是不错的，就导致有很多人。
放弃梦想。所以你可以理解啊，大张旗鼓的谈论梦想确实得先吃饱了，对吧？他们整个国家吃的挺饱，所以说呢他们就谈论梦想。在其实在大部分的文化里面，我们会主张珍惜眼前人。
珍惜已珍惜我们已经拥有的这是大部分的语境。但是在这样一个社会里面，对吧？失之愈合的语境里面，他他们就会会有一种很颓丧的那种会觉得我被耽误了，我其实可以更好，对吧？我其实可以更好。
是不同的语境。当然咱们在在咱们这里也有很强很大的受众。大家可以现在可以理解为什么文艺青年知识分子都很喜欢失之于合吗？也就是所谓的所谓的高职阶层啊，迷失之于和迷的都不不要不要的。
对呀，你看这位同学说，他以为男主会去接那个赌博漫画的工作，然后赚抚养费，然后珍惜眼前人，这就是我们的思路呀，我们就会这么写呀。同学们这个故事讲的就是啊我再强调一遍，他讲的就是一个蹉跎半生的一个落魄的一个中年人啊，是吧？
他面临的情况就是离异对吧？失业没钱，想要重新找回他自己啊找回他自己呢，在整个故事脉络呢，他做了哪几种努力呢，找钱是吧？找回失去的家庭是吧？发现都无所屌用。最后呢他想要找回梦想，就是这么一个。
脉络讲知识点之前，我们可以理一下这部电影因为也也有原版小说。这个大家知道吧？这个电影为什么台词那么多金剧那么多？因为它是有原版小说的啊，也是有小说积累的，所以会有大量的台词，大量的金剧。这个电影里面的金剧给大家印象最深的有哪些啊？比如说。
有勇气成为他人的过去。
才是成熟的男人。
是吧哎，这句同学说的对啊，我的人生到底从哪里开始不正常了呢？或者是说我的人生到底从哪里开始走错了呢？出问题了呢？怎么会走到现在呢？
另外刚才我给大家看的那场戏，对吧？不是每个人。
都能长成理想中的大人。
还有他妈妈说的幸福是要放弃一些东西才可以得到的。很多好台词是吧？确实很扎心啊，很扎心啊，说一下这个这个电影有哪些知识点值得我们去去学习啊。首先先理解一下什么是作者电影啊，我们说失之愈合的电影，大部分都是作者电影。当然了，他通过玩作者电影，玩红了以后。
也开始玩商业片了啊，也开始呃学磨着做赚点钱什么的。作者电影啊，一般来说自己写自己拍啊，自己搞钱，这就是作者电影啊。你如果想要拍作者电影，想要自我表达，想要不受约束，那么你至少要做到三件事情，自己写自己拍自己找钱。
为什么今天开课之前我就首先说了这句话，我不提倡大家写这种剧本。因为有些同学就说我也想写一个失之愈合那样的剧本，充满了自我表达，充满了台词和京剧啊，充满了慢悠悠的节奏，对生活的感悟。然后呢，到时候如果有好演员配一个好导演，我这个片肯定牛逼。
很多同学这么想。
我一直是持反对态度的，就是因为这种电影绝大部分都是作者电影。为什么叫作者电影？为什么作者可以畅快的自我表达，不受约束的自我表达，因为他至少要做三件事情，自己写自己倒，自己找钱，基本上缺一不可。
那么我们就来想一下。
刚才有很多同学已经说了。
如果这个电影我们做一下商业化改造。
怎么做开放思维啊？如果做一下商业化改造怎么做？有个同学说他是怎么找到的阿不欢。对呀，这不就是说嘛作者电影的作者要有足够的人格魅力，足够的人脉呀，你得能找到这些东西。我不是讲过吗？我们的贾樟柯导演不就这样吗？人家永远能找到牛逼演员能找到钱。
对不对？就是你你得有足够的这个power，有能力呀，你得有这个能力能找到各种人来加持你，然后支持你的自我表达嘛。来我们大家开放思维，如果这个故事我们要写商业片咋写？如果这个故事我们要写商业片咋写？有同学说让他的在终点时放弃梦想，珍惜家庭。
对，这是一种路子。追回前期。对，中彩票中彩票不行啊，中彩票无论是在商业片里面还是在文艺片里边都不太好啊啊哦一上来中彩票是可以的。我们来说一下啊，首先我们就来发掘挖掘一下目前这个故事有哪些商业点。
我们来先说一下目前这些故事有哪些商业有两个比较显性的商业点啊。第一个商业点，台风也就是说我们可以写一个台风夜台风大作战的故事，一个儿子跟他的妈妈跟他的姐姐，甚至跟他姐姐的小孩一家人利用台风大作战，想要把前妻和儿子挽回。
还有一种玩法呢是侦探，就是他是私家侦探这件事情听的。我们的主角私家侦探相当于一个小小的天眼和技能，他也是可以布控整个前妻，然后甚至可以跟他的儿子合伙，如何拆散他的前妻和这个不太受人待见的这个有钱的男朋友。当然了，你可以把这个有钱男朋友做成反派。
对吧让他坏一点，你看这就这又是一种思路，就说这是两个比较显性的商业元素。当然了，也可以基于现在的这个故事，把它改一种价值，让这个男人从追求梦想变成脚踏实地，这个是最简单的一种改法。
当然了也会很温情啊，就不至于太商业。同学们咱们可以试着写一写好不好？有些同学想尝试啊，可以基于这个故事现有的元素和人物，你自己重新排列组合，写一个商业的故事，好不好啊？同学们玩玩看，自己玩一玩，自己试一试。
肯定挺有意思。不是否定失之愈合，同学们搞清楚啊，动别这么去想啊，我们很尊敬他。我上来就说了，我个人很喜欢诗之玉合愈合每一部片子我都很喜欢。因为他这个叙事方式啊我觉得都还是不错的，玩的蛮舒服的。东方美。而且我为什么我觉得比海更深，我很能共情呢。我我也是少年。
少年成名。然后当然啦，在小县城啊，少年成名曾经很辉煌，取得过很大的成就啊，我不光没有啃老，我从上班就开始养家，对吧？我从上班就开始养家，给给给家里买房子，但是始终没有。
达到他们认为的那种高度。就是因为我小时候我得过什么画画比赛全省第一名物理竞赛省的一等奖考试也每次都是状元。然后所谓的神童啊，所谓的神童，年轻的时候就是。
辉煌过，但是这个辉煌啊，在我人踏入社会之后呢，我发现他兑现不了太多的东西，不可能说你小时候是神童，人家就得过一些奖，人家就别人1万块钱工资就给你5万不可能的。你懂吗？进到社会之后，我给大家讲一个很现实的例子啊，我在27岁那一年。
我曾经有一年大年三十。
从山东。
走了离家走了27岁，我当时大学毕业两年半。
我回家过年其实是挺骄傲的一个状态。为什么呢？因为我们当年啊你可以理解，就是200几年的时候，那时候平均工资是3000多，不务员白领的平均工资是3000多。你像我们工作两三年的话，平均工资能到四五千。我当时一个月最起码赚2万块钱。因为我天天请客，都我同学都找我蹭饭。
我还觉得自己挺人物人六的，就这么一个感觉吧，觉得自己挺好的。然后我27岁那年回春节回家过年，我爸妈他们俩就找我谈话啊，很很很严肃的把我叫在沙发上跟我谈话。因为我爸妈都是那种农村人啊，平常也不善言谈，其实不太讲话的。我们在家里没有交谈这个事项。所以我就感觉事事情很严重。
很严肃，很不一样。然后呢，他们就跟我说，他们说你的那个同学那个于某某听说刚买了1个200多平米的大房子在北京。
我说对我也听说了，然后他们又说，还有你那个小学的那个发小，他在上海听说买了一套。
叠拼啊400多的一个平方的一个叠拼。
我说是我说是。
我知道。
然后我以为他们接下来会说一句什么话呢？会说哎呀。
咱们家条件也不好。
爸爸妈妈也没有什么本事，不能给你买房子，对吧？不能给你东西，不能给你买房子。呃，但是咱没事，咱慢慢努力，对吧？你也挺优秀的，你自己加油。
我以为他们会说这个话。
结果他们接下来的话是。
那你怎么这么没出息呢？
你不是小时候学习比他俩都强吗？
就说了这么一句话，我当时就一下懵了，我当时就说啊，那么我们就忽略于某某的妈妈是公安局局长这件事吗？袁某某的爸爸是咱们这儿的金矿矿长这件事情，咱们就不提了吗？就是啊就是完全就是就是啊这个我以为。
就是工作两年，买了这个上千万的房子，400多平，就是他爸爸是是局长这件事情难道我们难道我们就忽略不计吗？但是确实我父母是不能理解这个问题，他们就会觉得同样是考试去了大城市。
人家肯定是有本事。
这是题外话啊，这是题外话。我就是想告诉你大家，我们像我们这种中年人啊。
你很难活成。
理想中的自己，我其实我当时挺有钱的，现在也挺有钱。
但是就是你没有办法活成理想成的自己，或者是说你没有办法让所有人满意。
做不到的。
虽然我没有像这个男主角一样去偷钱，去啃老，去当铺，去赌博。
这些事情我没有做过，但我依然能共情他。
我有可能活成他这样。
说一下今天的最后一个议题啊，同学们。
我虽然不提倡大家。
写文艺篇。
但是。
如果。
我们要写这样一个片子。
我们该怎么写？
挺矛盾的是吧？
我再强调一遍，我不提倡你们任何一个新人脑子没给我憋着，我要得奖，我要表达，我要当事之愈合，我不提倡。
但是。
如果你要写这种类型的片子。
我教你怎么写。
有三个特点。第一个特点，叙事分段。
不用太清楚。
比如说啊如果是商业片，我们说这个片子分三拍，找钱找家庭，找梦想。
同学们设想一下设想啊，如果这是一个商业，你就劝劝他。
说这个故事我不去动你的表达，不去动你的结构。咱们改的稍微商业那么一点，可不可以？
三拍。
找钱作为第一part，明确的找明确的有一个目标，把那幅画做的明确一点，是不是被当初的密了，是不是藏在姐姐那里啊，把找画这件事情作为第一幕或作为第一part，对吧？给我明确的写出跌宕起伏。
第二拍找家庭，跟踪自己的前妻呃攻击他的现男友呃，嗯派自己的儿子当卧底，甚至派给自己的儿子东西，让自己的儿子去栽赃那个人把第二拍也给我坐实。然后第三拍呢找梦想，钱和家庭都过掉之后，我开始追求自己的梦想，我还是要成为小说家，对吧？我要参加一个什么什么那个那个。
呃，投稿我要参加一个什么什么，把这三篇写的干干净净。
劲儿都顶到足。
如果是我们我们就会这么做。
那么你就可以理解，这是文艺片的第一个特点。
他的每个目标的紧迫感和牵引力以及分段都不太清楚，都揉在一起。
就是他明明有三个目标，但是分段很不清晰，而且每一个目标都没有很强的紧迫感和牵引力。在日本。
有一个术语叫什么啊？叫脱力，没有牵引力，没有紧迫感，是吧？甚至在日本这都是个文学流派，叫托立派。文艺片的第二个特点，静态西多啊静态西多。
拔断的台词洗。
用台词来交代信息，用台词静态稀多啊，静态稀多，用台词来推进剧情。
这是第二个特点。
当然了，前两个特点都是表象的啊，都是表现形式的。
最重要的是第三个特点。
以文艺片跟商业片最大的区别是第三个特点。
叫客气。
文艺片是克制的艺术。
他把所有的事情点到为止，但就不再继续往下推进了。
特制啊也叫留白啊，留白是一种比较特是一种比较典型的东方审美。
咱们东方人不管是画画也好啊，这个这个这个拍东西也好，比较注意留白啊，认为这是一种克制，这是一种艺术。这与我们的文化底蕴是有关系的啊。我先说一下克制的原理啊。
咱们东方人其实一直有克制方面的原理，我们以克制为美。
咱们就以穿衣服为例啊，画画大家都理解，你看咱们的国画大量的留白，我们就以穿衣服为例啊。
我再直白点讲啊，咱们东方人的传统衣服。
一直不太舒服。
比如说男的穿长衫，女的穿旗袍都一直不太舒服，为什么呢？
因为我们骨子里啊有一种病态神美，就是不舒服为美，不舒服为高雅。
你自己体会一下。
咱们很多艺术都是这样，就穿这衣服没法干活。
走路也不得劲儿，这是我们骨子里面的一种审美。你看啊。
我们比如说那个我们画画也是梅花，我们喜欢画并梅是吧？要歪歪扭扭的，我们认为好看。
蓬勃发展的枝繁叶茂的，我们觉得不美，对吧？一切以克制为美。
一切以隐忍为美。
穿衣服也是这样。
就是与不用干活有关系。
所以说在西方文明里面，只有在中世纪，在古代女性才有以束服为美，穿的很束服，穿着不能干活，以此为美。后来就迅速这个文化就没了。但在咱们东方呢，咱们一直传承到现在啊，一直克制。有个同学说这是阶级的问题。，你不要去聊阶级，就算是阶级的问题。那审美不也是阶级影响的吗？
你能跳脱出自己去理解这个所谓的审美吗？
底层也决定不了审美啊。
大家可以理解为什么东方有克制这个审美，有留白这个审美啊，我们先理解它的原理。
要理解他。
我们东方人为什么喜欢时时愈合啊？本身我们有这个审美。
同学们。
我们知道原理不代表否定他。
有很多同学啊由于不喜欢不喜欢任何人去诋毁失之愈合，所以就不喜欢人去分析原理。
分析原理不代表诋毁他明白吗？
我经常举一个例子，同学们。
咱们在座的各位都是受过教育的知识分子。我提问大家一个问题。
鸡汤从分子结构会有什么营养吗？
从分子的角度。
鸡汤有什么营养吗？
对吧你拿到实验室里去化验一下，一只鸡煮煮成汤，出来的就是嘌呤和脂肪，蛋白质可以完全忽略不计，对吧？
这个是从客观的角度讲，肯定不如吃鸡肉有营养。
但是喝鸡汤是我们的文化。
不代表我们知道原理，不代表我们不喜欢它。
懂吗？我知道鸡汤没营养，但是我依然喜欢喝鸡汤。
不能有人说。
老师，你竟然诋毁鸡汤，你诋毁我们中国的传统文化，不能这么去想问题。
明白吗？
不耽误。
我们知道我们东方人为什么克制，为什么喜欢留白，这是一种这是一种我们自己的传统审美。我们知道原理不代表它就不美了啊，不代表我们要诋毁谁，好吧。
你先要理解什么叫留白，什么叫克耻？什么叫东方审美，以及他。
为什么在我们的血液里啊？为什么在我们的基因里？
然后我们再回到电影故事。
在电影故事当中，我们如何克制如何留白呢？
举几个简单的例子。
彩票中奖了吗？
彩票中没多啊？
是不是啊？
前期有没有和那个那个男朋友在一起啊？
对吧。
男主角有没有去？
把那个赚钱的。
漫画的那个活接了。
会不会去接啊？
不一定不一定。
谁道啊。
一切都是这。
点到为止。
很客气。
客体。
都不发满力对吧？有目标也不满力去追求，不发满力去po使这个目标啊，结果也不展示。
所以如果大家喜欢文艺片啊，可以根据我刚才说的这些自己再看一看好不好？自己再看一看。有个同学说能不能趁这个片子讲讲静态系怎么写，静态系就是没什么推进呀。
首先他没有动作转场，就在同同一个场景里面不停的叨不进叨逼叨。第二呢是讲完之后，人物的状态没有变化，没往前推，全部在交代信息。因为整个戏的状态变化次数不多，商业片是每场戏都有状态变化。我本来这场戏想偷钱，然后这场戏发现操偷钱错了，我要找下一个目标，找到下一个目标，发现这个人是我的仇家，然后这个人是我仇家，然后下一个目标去了之后就发现他其实有还有别的线索，我其实现在不能杀他。
就每场戏都有状态变化。
商业片，你去看别种剧，每场戏都有状态变化。
我们的商业片也是要求每一场戏都引起变化。
静态戏就是它没变化。这场戏。
讲完了之后还是没什么变化，没有理解母亲是吧？也没有说产生一个新的欲望。
很多场都没有，对吧？当然不能说每场都是静态戏，每场都是静态戏，那完蛋了。我只是说他很多静态戏偏多，好吧，那今天就这样吧。